mesdames memoiselles messieurs bonjour
10000 km en quelques jours qure grands
discours 20 àocution c'est le programme
de la visite officielle de 8 jours que
le président Pompidou va effectuer aux
états le Président et Madame Pompidou
doivent quitter horlit aujourd'hui à
13h30 ce soir ils passeront la première
nuit de leur voyage aux États-Unis dans
la résidence présidentielle de cand
David je pense que nous allons avoir une
carte détaillée de ce séjour la
résidence de cand David qui se trouve à
80 km environ à vol d'oiseau de
Washington demain et mercredi le
président Pompidou et le président Nixon
auront deux entretiens jeudi le
Président et Madame Pompidou se rendront
à Cap Kennedy où ils visiteront les
installations de la NASA les les
dernières étapes de ce voyage seront San
Francisco Chicago et New York d'où le
Président et Madame Pompidou
s'envoleront pour Paris le 3 mars en
prélude à cette visite officielle le
magazine américain Time a publié
aujourd'hui une interview que le
président Pompidou lui avait accordé le
14 février parlant des relations
franco-américaines le président français
déclare il y a peut-être des divergences
de vue étant donné que la France entend
conserver sa liberté de jugement mais
par essence et en ce qui concerne les
objectifs nous sommes en réalité soit en
accord soit très près l'un de l'autre et
à propos des éventuelles manifestations
qui risquent de marquer le séjour du
président Pompidou le président français
a dit c'est le genre de chose qui ne
m'inquiète jamais j'espère que cela
n'aura pas d'aspect déplaisant pour les
relations amicales entre la France et
les États-Unis dans le courant de ce
journal je pense que nous pourrons
entrer en liaison avec George pit qui
est à Orly et qui nous fera assister au
départ de l'avion
présidentiel les experts qui enquêtent
en Suisse sur la catastrophe aérienne
qui a fait samedi 47 morts n'écarte pas
l'hypothèse de l'attentat ils estiment
que la catastrophe a été provoquée par
un incendie dont les causes sont encore
inconnues les enquêteurs ont en leur
possession le dernier message que le
commandant de bord du Coronado de la
suissire a envoyé à la tour de contrôle
ce message disait je crois qu'il s'est
produit une explosion dans le
compartiment arrière je peux à peine
voir le tableau de bord tant il y a de
fumée je vais faire demi-tour prévenez
la police afin qu'elle ouvre une enquête
en Israël en tout cas il ne fait pas de
doute que personne ne doute plutôt qu'il
s'agisse d'un attentat et l'ont fait le
rapprochement avec l'explosion qui a
endommagé samedi également une caravelle
autrichienne certains experts israéliens
disent que les deux explosions ont été
provoqués par des colis piégés qui
étaient réglés pour sauter à une
certaine altitude conséquence de cette
catastrophe certains pays ont décidé de
suspendre l'envoi de colis aériens à
destination d'Israël c'est le cas
notamment de l'Allemagne fédérale et
dans la plupart des aéroports d'Europe
les mesures de sécurité ont été
renforcées ce matin à zu 11 personnes
seulement se sont embarquées à
destination de Tel Aviv sur le vol 332 6
personnes ont annulé leur réservation
préférant partir d'un autre
aéroport la surveillance est peu visible
mais d'après les autorités constantes
les bagages sont fouillés chaque
passagers priait de venir reconnaître
ses valises à la demande des compagnies
les bagages peuvent être passés au rayon
X afin d'y déceler des objets
métalliques suspect l'appareil à
destination de Tel Aviv qui est parti ce
matin avait été éloigné de 200 m des
autres avions et spécialement
surveillé sur le plan politique et
diplomatique madame Golda va faire
aujourd'hui une déclaration sur cette
catastrophe devant la cesset qui est le
parlement israélien madame Goldin ma qui
est le premier ministre israélien a reçu
matin les ambassadeurs accrédités des
pays qui ont une compagnie qui ont des
compagnies aériennes elle va tenter de
les persuader de ne pas mettre en
application la décision qui a été prise
par hier par un certain nombre de
compagnies européennes de suspendre
l'acheminement du du matériel et du
courrier à destination
d'Israël voici d'ailleurs la réunion de
ce conseil des ministres
hier sous la présidence de Madame
goldamer s'est donc tenu ce conseil des
ministres israéliens un certain nombre
de mesures ont été prises mais madame
goldamer en réserve la primeure à la
cisset le parlement israélien où cet
après-midi elle doit faire une
déclaration spéciale sa déclaration du
Premier ministre est certainement très
importante puisque ce matin madame maire
devait recevoir les ambassadeurs des 10
pays ayant des communication aérienne
avec telavive on se souvient que les
Israéliens avaient déclaré nous ne
saurons tolérer que les transports
israéliens soient impunément
perturbé
ici comme à son habitude le général
moched Dayan arrive au conseil en
hélicoptère un absent au cours de ce
conseil des ministres israéliens
monsieur abban le ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui poursuit sa tournée des
capitales européenne il se trouve
actuellement en Allemagne fédérale là
après avoir été reçu par Monsieur shell
son homologue allemand il s'est rendu
aussitôt en hélicoptère à l'ancien camp
de concentration nazi monsieur abban
était accompagné d'ancien détenus
allemand membre du gouvernement régional
de
Bavière après s'être rendu au musée où
sont conservés photos et souvenirs sous
un vent glacial il s'est recueilli
devant le monument international élevé
en souvenir de tous ceux qui ont péri
dans ce camp de la mort monsieur abban Y
a déposé une couronne au couleur
d'Israël ill blanc et iris bleu sans
avoir dit un mot au journaliste monsieur
abban a regagné Munich son séjour en
Allemagne fédérale dura jusqu'à
mercredi
au après le bombardement de l'usine
d'abouzabal le gouvernement égyptien a
décidé l'application de sévères mesures
de blackout dans les deux grandes villes
Alexandrie et le K tous les phares des
automobiles doivent être peints en bleu
les autobus également tous les rverber
et les ensins lumineux seront
éteints quant au vitres des bâtiments si
elles ne sont pas recouvertes de
peinture elles doivent être obscurcies
par des rideau lourds ou du pied opaque
toute personne ne seblliant pas à ce
règlement sera puni et toujours à propos
de cette catastrophe aérienne auquel on
estime que si Israël dit ce sont les
palestiniens qui ont provoqué la
catastrophe c'est uniquement pour
discréditer la cause PAL palestinienne
pardon aux yeux de l'opinion mondiale en
tout cas les Palestiniens hier à Aman en
Jordanie ont enregistré un succès sur le
plan disons diplomatique le roi Husain
de Jordanie et les organisations de
résist ance palestinienne sont arrivés à
un accord cet accord réglementerait la
le port d'armes et l'usage de ces armes
par les guerriéros Palestiniens les
Jordaniens auraient fait dit-on un
certain nombre de concessions au
Palestiniens si bien qu'aujourd'hui les
observateurs estiment que cette accord
marque en fait la naissance d'un État
palestinien dans l'état
jordanien France deux informations
d'ordre social à la SNCF les six
syndicats qui ont accepté dans la nuit
de jeudi à vendredi l'accord de la SNCF
vont signé cet accord cet après-midi
avec la direction de la SNCF la CGT n'a
pas accepté à refusé de signer cet
accord qui porte sur les salaires le
pouvoir d'achat et la durée du temps de
travail enfin dans l'aviation le trafic
est perturbé dans certains aéroports de
province car le personnel au sol
d'Air-France est en grève pour 24 heures
cette action a pour but de défendre les
garanties de l'emploi des agents
information générale Michel Fau et
Thérèse lemadre doivent être entendus
aujourd'hui par le juge d'instruction de
Soisson mademoiselle Tanzanie la
reconstitution de l'enlèvement de la
petite Sophie du gay aura lieu dans les
jours qui viennent au chapitre des
informations et bien des inondations
pardon la scne le doux et la Moselle
sont en cru et sur le rein la navigation
a dû être interrompue voilà qu'il ne va
pas falciliter le tourisme qui revient
pourtant qui ne va pas tarder à être
d'actualité puisque les vacances d'hiver
sont presque terminées et que l'on va
bientôt parler des vacances d'été alors
il est temps pour nous de parler de
tourisme avec
sou alors cette année c'est l'Italie
l'Espagne ou la Côte d'Azur quel que
soit le lieu de vos vacances sachez que
cette extraordinaire migration vers le
soleil est un mouvement qui ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui la plupart des invasions
comme celle des has des godes des
visigodes ou des vandales prenaient la
même direction celle qui mène vers le
sud les motivations étaient probablement
les mêmes attraction du soleil recherche
de l'aventure et du dépaysement ces
envahisseurs et ses touristes ont aussi
en commun le fait de vivre sur le pays
la comparaison s'arrête là car les
premiers pillers tandis qu'aujourd'hui
les touristes payent en devise leur
nourriture et leur logement c'est là
toute la différence une différence qui
fait que le tourisme est devenu une
industrie mais pour qu'une industrie
soit rentable il faut qu'elle soit
compétitive c'est pour cela que des
organismes de tourisme comme le club
Méditerrané et le CET longtemps
concurrents se sont d'une part réunis
pour offrir à leur clientèle un plus
grand choix de vacances et d'autre part
rentabiliser leur gestion en se servant
par exemple d'ordinateur qui permettent
entre autres de gagner du temps voici un
exemple je voudrais partir au
Méditerrané au mois d'avril pour de
semaines oui Agad vous conviendrait très
bien oui parfait de semaines le 2 avril
très
bien
voiciac nous
av son pour
person
douil
ternelle dois faire maintenant plus
laaiss ves de Mar com vacances d'ici 10
ans par exemple au début les vacances si
on monte seulement à 36 c'était
simplement redécouvrir son corps
maintenant c'est déjà redécouvrir son
corps et sa tête et demain ce sera
sûrement apprendre à s'enrichir nous
pensons déjà dès maintenant à avoir dans
nos villages en même temps que l'évasion
le soleil et la mer des cours
d'audiovisuel par exemple pourquoi ne
pas apprendre une langue étrangère quand
on est dans un pays étranger pourquoi ne
pas apprendre à lire plus vite quand on
est en vacances pourquoi ne pas
apprendre tout ce qu'on voudra apprendre
pourquoi ne pas apprendre ce que c'est
que l'informatique quand on est en
vacances et puis après grâce à cette
apprentissage fait en décontraction et
et en détente s'enrichir réellement en
pratiquant cette ce qu'on a appris ou
commencer à apprendre ou entrevu
d'apprendre en appliquant un nouveau
métier vous savez c'est à peu près fini
maintenant qu'un homme 10 à 17 ans je
ferai ce métier là toute ma vie et
finisse à 65 ans avec sa retraite dans
la génération qui vient on fera cinq
métiers et peut-être le temps du vacan
ça sera le temps d'apprendre de nouveaux
métiers de recyclage recyclage
ou l'avenir est plein de promesses mais
si les Français partent de plus en plus
à l'étranger les étrangers eux viennent
de moins en moins en France la balance
touristique au prier semestre 1969
serait déficitaire cela malgré des
investissements supérieurs à tous nos
voisins le tourisme français semble
manquer d'une organisation à l'échelon
national euh monsieur le ministre
qu'envisagez-vous pour relancer le
tourisme il ne suffit pas bien sûr de
dire aux gens venez chez nous encore
faut-il bien préparer les conditions
dans lesquelles ils viennent à nous bien
convenir des éléments de ce qui doit
être l'accueil de ce qui doit être
l'hébergement faire en sorte que ces
conditions de confort et et d'agrément
soit réuni et convenir surtout non
seulement du respect quant à la qualité
de la prestation mais animer leur séjour
et animer tout ce qui constitue cet
ensemble vacancier de façon telle que
ceux qui sont en vacances ne s'ennuient
pas en ne perdant jamais de vue que il y
a au travers de l'Europe au travers du
monde une très vaste compétition qui
porte autant sur la qualité des
prestations que sur les prix bien sûr et
puis ce je ne sais quoi qui fait qu'en
définitive on n plus beso plus tenté
d'aller vers un pays que vers un autre
parce que on y a ce sentiment de se
retrouver à son aise de se retrouver
chez soi le sentiment d'y être attendu
nous allons parler de sport maintenant
avec Jean-Michel lolot et tout d'abord
de ski oui avec la confirmation des
résultat vous savez qu'avec le décalage
horaire qui existe entre l'Europe et les
États-Unis nous n'avions eu que hier le
résultat de la première manche du slum
spécial dame de Jackson hall dans le
Wyoming pour être précis et bien c'est
Ingrid lafor qui a confirmé sa victoire
elle était champion du monde la 2è c'est
Barbara kokranaméricaine à 1 seconde 48
cè voyez l'écart qui sépare la première
de la 2è 3è Beny Clifford la Canadienne
4e Brit la forg la sœur de la gagnante
notons que au classement de la Coupe du
Monde c'est toujours Michel Jaco qui est
en tête devant Françoise maquy et
Florence sterer mais Michel Jaco est
tombé et Françoise maquy a été
disqualifié hier il y avait aussi
confirmation des résultats du slalom
spéciau du slalom spécial homme c'est
Alain Pen qui a gagné devant brchu à une
seconde et Gustavo Toni à 2 secondes du
vainqueur schrance ne termine que 7e
mais il a dit qu'il avait voulu assurer
son classement à la Coupe du monde où il
est toujours en tête devant Patrick
Russel maintenant en rugby c'était hier
vous le savez la dernière journée des
poules de 8 avec un match intéressant la
qualification de montmarsan était en jeu
pour les 16e de finale c'est Claude
mdieux qui nous en parle
maintenant le Stade Montois à droite sur
votre écran en maillot cerclé recevez
donc Condon pour cette dernière journée
des poules de H8 du championnat pour les
Montois dont la qualification pour les
16e de finale a toujours été remise en
question il ne fallait pas perdre cette
rencontre en fait l'église intercalée
donnait à Clavé qui permettait à Mton de
marquer le premier essai pour les moin
3-0 les joueurs de Condon devaient alors
prendre le match en main et Comé devait
marquer un premier essai qui sera suivi
par deux autres tant la troisème ligne
de Condon était vive et efficace les
Montois marquaient un essai par leur
demi de mêlé du Martin et qui sera
transformé mais ici c'est le deuxème
essai de
Condon une pénalité réussie permettait à
Condon de porter la marque à 14 à 8 à la
mi-temps en début de 2è mi-temps Condon
et montmarsan marquent chacun tr
la marque est alors de 17 à 11 lorsque
vous l'avez vu les montoir réussissent
un nouvel essai 17 à 14 et regardez bien
ceci car vous allez voir avec quelle
hargne et quelle volonté les Montois
vont construire l'essai qui va leur
permettre de gagner cette rencontre 19 à
17 car cet essai va être
transformé
et c'est finalement Jean doga qui
marquera l'essai de la
victoire et bien geor P nous signale que
le Président et Madame Pompidou sont
arrivés à il y a quelques instants alors
j'en profite pour appeler tout de suite
George pit à
or
ici le salon d'honneur à
horli il est 13h10 nous assistons au
prier épisode d'un voyage dont on va
beaucoup parler dans les jours à venir
le président Pidou est en train de
prendre congé des membr du gouvernement
viêre accil par Monsieur prier
ministre sont ici pour l'accueillir
également les membres du corps
diplomatique et lesésentant l'ambassade
des ÉtatsUnis bien
entendu dans quelques minutes après
qu'un détachement militaire aura rendu
les honneur monsieur Pompidou montera à
bord du DC8 présidentiel qui à 13h30
doit décoller
d'Orly pour s'envoler vers Washington le
DC8 présidentielle atterrira à la base
militaire d'Andrews à 16h he locale soit
à 2h he de
Paris la suite présidentielle comporte
14 personnes dont notamment monsieur
Maurice Schuman ministre des affffaires
étrangères et Madame Schuman et
l'ambassadeur de France à Washington et
Madame Charles
Lucet la visite officielle commence
demain
mardi c'est demain matin en effet que le
président Nixon recevra sur la pelouse
de la Maison Blanche le président
pompidon la partie proprement politique
de ce voyage se déroulera pendant les
trois premiers jours c'est-à-dire demain
après-demain et Jeudi 3 jours au cours
desquels monsieur
Pompidou aura 3 ou 4 heures
d'entretien avec le président Nixon
rencontrera les principaux ministres du
gouvernement américain dont le ministre
de la Défense le ministre des Affaires
étrangères et le ministre des Finances
mercredi le président de la République
doit prononcer un discours au capital de
ant les deux Chambres réunies du
Congrès et jeudi matin il doit avoir un
deuxè et dernier entretien politique
avec le président
Nixon à partir de jeudi après-midi c'est
une visite à l'américaine en quelques
sorte que le président
Pompidou
il semble bien entendu que les
États-Unis que le gouvernement des
États-Unis soit décidé à poursuivre une
politique d'amitié et de rapprochement
avec la
France et on peut dire que le
gouvernement américain attend de la
visite de Monsieur Pompidou aux
États-Unis que cette visite réaffirme
que telle est également la politique du
gouvernement
français voici je pense que l'avion va
dégaler dans quelques
minutes
dans un peu plus de
6h l'avion présidentiel atterrira la
base militaire à Washington et c'est
demain matin que commencera la visite
officielle ici
or à vous vous
COG non pardon dit que nous avons
toujours
l'image
à partir de jeudi le président Pompidou
entamera une visite qu'on pourrait
qualifier de à l'américaine visite très
rapide des États-Unis puisque jeudi
matin jeudi en fin de matinée il doit
s'envoler pour Cap Kennedy en Floride
visiter les installations de la
NASA puis le même jour prendre l'avion
pour San Francisco c'est-à-dire à
quelques 4000 km à l'ouest le voyage
pant lequel il survolera dans toute leur
largeur l'ensemble des
États-Unis après l'étape de San
Francisco il se rendra à Chicago et
enfin à New York
par et c'est donc le 3 mars que le
Président et Madame Pompidou regagneront
la France Jacqueline Alexandre je crois
que nous allons parler d'un sujet
beaucoup plus léger oui en effet nous
allons parler de chichi vous savez le
fameux panda dont les amours malheureux
ont inspiré une série de croquis par le
dessinateur Dropy n'est-ce pas Daniel
Casal et bien oui vous vous souvenez
sans doute de chichi ce panda du eau de
Londres qui se mourrait d'amour en
attendant un fiancé le fiancé se
présenta et Anan venait des lointaines
pleines d'Ukraine mais chichi le
dédaigna Anan retourna d'où il était
venu et Chichi se reprit à rêver de l'AM
sœur l'amsœur chichi ne tarda pas à la
flairer dans la cage voisine un âne
sauvage tu seras mon âne superbe et
généreux lui confi chichi mais les
gardiens du zoau de Londres ne
l'entendirent pas de cette oreille car
si l'Angleterre a créé la min jupe elle
n'a pu accepter cet amour impossible
chichi aujourd'hui tricote sans espoir
en pensant au jour prochain où elle
soupirera mon âne me célébrait du temps
que j'étais
belle c'est le pâtissier d'un petit
village au confin d'élande et du
Pays-Basque qui nous a proposé cette
recette qu'à notre tour nous vous
proposons
aujourd'hui c'est ce gâteau bas que vous
le réaliserez en deux temps il vous faut
de 250 g de confiture pour le qu/4 de
œufs 125 g de beurre de farine et de
sucre un demi paquet de levure une
cuillerée à soupe de rhum pour la crème
pâtissière un/4 de litre de lait à neuf
70 g de sucre 35 g de farine un sachet
de sucre vanillé une cuillée de Rob pour
la crème pâtissière vous faites chauffer
le lait travaillez l'œuf
entier avec le sucre
vanillé le sucre en
poudre
et enfin la
farine délayz progressivement avec le
lait très
chaud transvasz le tout dans la
casserole et mettez à bouillir sur feu
doux en ant constamment ajoutez un trait
de
RH puis mettez à
refroidir pendant ce temps prépareer la
pâte à qu/ travailleer le beurre qui
doit prendre une consistance
crémeuse ajouez le sucre
mélangeer mettez les œufs
entiers ajoutez enfin la
farine
le
Rome et la levure en dernier
lieu
beurerez un moule à
génoise dans lequel vous verserez les de
tiers de la
pâte que vous étalerez en remontant sur
les
bords versez dans le creux la
confiture que vous recouvrirez
entièrement de crème pâtissière bien
refroidie déposeer le reste de pâte à
gâteau à la
surface
lisser
mettez au four et faites cuire à feu
modéré ce gâteau se sert refroidi vous
pouvez le sapoudrer de sucre glace à
travers une grille à pâtisserie pour
former des petits
dessins en guise de dessert la Bourse de
Paris à vous Gérard
Palance c'est un marché aujourd'hui sans
beaucoup d'entrain mais tout de même
résistant
cela grâce à la bonne tenue des grandes
valeurs françaises et en tête on voit
des valeurs comme l'air liquide
péchinpoulin Michelin la Compagnie
générale d'électricité qui ont monté
ainsi que Perrier et les Presses de la
Cité qui avaient fléchi ces derniers
temps à côté des grandes valeurs
françaises il y a
également